hey leute kann der flügelschlag eines
schmetterlings einen sturm auslösen
vielleicht ist dieser kleine luftstoß
der tropfen der das fass zum überlaufen
bringt wie sensibel reagiert unsere welt
auch veränderungen
jeden tag treffen wir entscheidungen
bewusst oder unbewusst oft sind das
triviale entscheidungen was er sich
heute zu mittag schreibe ich noch kurze
nachricht dass ich drei minuten zu spät
komme und welches buch lese ich heute
abend dinge die im normalfall schnell
wieder vergessen sind und keinen allzu
großen einfluss auf unser leben haben
manchmal sind diese entscheidungen auch
schon grösser wo machen wir dieses jahr
urlaub und soll ich mir jetzt schon das
neue auto kaufen und ab und zu treffen
wir die wirklich wichtigen
entscheidungen
und spätestens hier kann es passieren
dass man irgendwann vielleicht erst
jahre später stehen bleibt und sich
fragt was wäre wenn ich mich anders
entschieden hätte wo würde ich jetzt
stehen
was macht mein alternatives ich gerade
was wir aber nicht sehen sind die
kleinen entscheidungen die unser leben
tagtäglich verändern welche auswirkungen
hatte es dass ich heute fünf minuten
länger liegen geblieben bin weil ich
einfach so müde war vielleicht gar keine
aber vielleicht bleibe ich auch deswegen
im stau hängen den ich sonst gerade noch
so um fahren hätte wer weiß vielleicht
gehe ich deswegen einem tödlichen unfall
oder ich verpasse einen wichtigen anruf
und verliere einen kunden und die firma
muss dicht machen
das ist der butterfly effect der effekt
dass ein komplexes system wie unsere
welt auf die kleinsten veränderungen
sehr empfindlich reagieren kann das zum
beispiel der flügelschlag eines
schmetterlings nur durch eine lange
kettenreaktion die sich immer weiter
hochgeschaukelt
am anderen ende der welt einen sturm
auslöst
ein pendel wie dieses jahr zeichnet
willkürliche zufällige muster aber eine
sache ist besonders interessant
es ist von seiner startposition
unglaublich abhängig die kleinsten
änderungen der pendel zu beginn führen
schon nach wenigen sekunden zu komplett
unterschiedlichen mustern auf dem papier
die beziehung zwischen zwei pendeln ist
so empfindlich dass selbst supercomputer
ihre bewegungen höchstens ein paar
sekunden vorhersagen können es gibt
einfach viel zu viele einflussfaktoren
im jahr 1998 wurde dieses gebetsbuch
eines mönchs aus dem vierzehnten
jahrhundert für zwei millionen dollar
versteigert das buch enthielt
augenscheinlich nur christliche gebete
gebeten dies auch in tausenden anderen
büchern zu lesen gibt
was macht dieses buch also so wertvoll
der anonyme käufer ließ das buch
wissenschaftlich analysieren
es wurde mit verschiedenen
lichtwellenlängen gescannt und
durchleuchtet und was unter den gebeten
zum vorschein kam war unglaublich
es waren detaillierte rechnungen und
skizzen von archimedes einem der
bedeutendsten mathematiker der antike
nachdem archimedes skizzenbuch vor 2200
jahren verloren ging
taucht es anscheinend im 14 jahrhundert
in einer münch blutig wieder auf aber
anstatt den unglaublich wertvollen
inhalt auch zu bewahren und zu
veröffentlichen
kratzen der mensch die tinte vom papier
drehte es um 90 grad und schrieb seine
gebete darauf heute wissen wir dass
archimedes auf diesen seiten die
grundlage dafür schuf differenzial und
integralrechnung betreiben zu können
etwas das erst im 17 jahrhundert 1800
jahre später von leibnitz und newton
geschafft wurde
was wäre wenn archimedes der durchbruch
gelungen wäre oder wenn zumindest im 14
jahrhundert dieser mensch seine
schriften nicht beinahe vernichtet hätte
wären wir als menschheit jetzt weiter
hätte die industrielle revolution
mehrere hundert jahre früher eingesetzt
und wir würden heute schon andere
sternensysteme bevölkern
wer weiß das schon das ist die sache mit
dem butterfly effect in unserer welt
kann so viel passieren alles beeinflusst
sich gegenseitig es ist unmöglich
vorherzusagen was passieren wird
vielleicht wären wir als menschheit
schon viel weiter oder vielleicht ist es
auch genau so gekommen wie es kommen
musste
was ist wenn archimedes einfach vor
seiner zeit war viel zu früh mit seinen
mathematischen berechnungen
es gibt ein interessantes phänomen das
genau dafür spricht als newton und
gottfried wilhelm leibniz hatten im 17
jahrhundert unabhängig von archimedes
die infiniti sie mal rechnung erfunden
aber sie haben sie auch unabhängig
voneinander erfunden und das beinahe
zeitgleich so zeitgleich sogar dass
zwischen den beiden ein streit darum
entbrannt wer es zuerst geschafft hatte
und welchem land somit die leistung
zuzuschreiben ist
charles darwin gilt heute als der vater
der evolutionstheorie
aber alfred russel wallace hatte mehr
oder weniger die gleiche idee zur selben
zeit und alexander graham bell und
lagreat reichten am selben tag eine
patentanmeldung für das telefon ein
die geschichte zeigt uns wenn jemand
etwas bahnbrechendes entdeckt das den
fortschritt der menschheit nach vorne
treibt gibt es häufig andere die auf
demselben weg sind und gerade dabei
waren sehr ähnliche ideen umzusetzen
es ist ein so häufig auftretendes
phänomen das man ihm einen namen gegeben
hat multiple discovery oder auf deutsch
mehrfache entdeckung
es gibt eine wikipedia liste mit über
200 einträgen in dem mehrere menschen
bei einer zeitgleich die gleichen
entdeckungen machten
vielleicht ist es also durch den
fortschritt der menschheit
vorgeschrieben wann welche entdeckungen
gemacht werden da vinci war mit seinen
erfindungen wie helikoptern und
hydraulischen brücken einfach seiner
zeit voraus
die gesellschaft konnte damit noch
nichts anfangen und dinge wie die
atombombe und mussten einfach erfunden
werden alle puzzleteile waren vorhanden
und es war nur eine frage der zeit bis
sie jemand zusammensetzte wie dem auch
sei die geschichte ist so gekommen wie
sie gekommen ist und liegt jetzt
unveränderbar hinter uns alles was wir
machen können ist uns bewusst zu machen
dass alles was wir tun einen effekt auf
alles andere haben kann mein video hat
euch jetzt gerade fünf minuten lang
beschäftigt hätte ich das video nicht
gemacht dann würde die jetzt gerade alle
etwas anderes tun
vielleicht würdet ihr für die nächste
klausur lernen und deswegen keine
schlechte noten schreiben oder
vielleicht würdet ihr einfach nur ein
anderes youtube video gucken was auch
immer ihr tut
ich habe auf jeden fall gerade die welt
verändert und keiner kann sagen welche
auswirkungen das hat